cinquante mille enfants ont été
scolarisés à la maison en france cette
année
cela pourrait ne plus être possible sauf
exception cela fait partie du projet de
loi pour lutter contre les séparatismes
annoncé par emmanuel macron c'est pour
pouvoir continuer l'instruction à
domicile que près de 200 personnes ont
manifesté à versailles le système en
place fonctionne déjà très bien c'est à
dire que on est contrôlée par la mairie
par l'éducation nationale
il ya déjà tout un arsenal législatif
coût pleinement fonctionnelle alors
après s'il ya un manque de moyens il
faudrait peut-être pallier à ce manque
de moyens mais comme ya aucun lien qui
est fait entre
le séparatisme ou une quelconque forme
d'extrémisme et l'instruction en famille
je ne comprends pas cette fois en fait
les parents présents veulent aussi
montrer qui ils sont chaque situation
familiale est différente et chacun a ses
propres raisons de faire l'école à la
maison sont nés là aussi c'est avec
certaines revendications et pour
rappeler certains principes de base pour
nous la liberté c'est un fait c'est un
droit qui constitue notre patrie et pour
nous c'est insoutenable de penser que la
liberté finalement elle n'est plus ce
principe général est que l'exception va
devenir la règle
pourquoi ce principe il est il est
essentiel il a été très bien pensé c'est
que la loi ne pourra jamais pensé à
toute cette diversité de situations le
projet de loi globale sur la lutte
contre les séparatismes devrait être
présenté en conseil des ministres début
décembre